okay fine crater do decimal places the
value each pronumeral are we trying to
find a side or an angle we're trying to
find a side a so therefore which of
these am I going to use I'll use this
one because this is geared to find the
side here it is this is good to find the
angle okay so I'm going to look at this
I'm not going to write the formula down
because I noticed my formula has the
letter A knit this has a letter A but
they're not the same
oh okay so watch carefully in this
triangle the side I'm after is on the
left-hand side that's a so I'm gonna say
a squared okay then I launch into my
cosine rule and it starts off just like
Pythagoras starts off right what are the
other two sides six and ten so I've got
six squared and ten squared and then I'm
going to subtract to a because C so two
here's a here's B and then I do cause of
what in this case they only give you one
angle which is 56 degrees but remember
if you actually did get told what these
angles were how do you in terms of
position how do you know this is
actually actually the angle you want it
is opposite the side you want does that
make sense so there's the cosine rule
now this thing here is calculator fodder
right - go ahead punch that into your
calculator you're going to get some
messy decimal stuff in there which is
fine could someone give me 3 or 4
decimal places on their answer three or
four dozen places what are you getting
yeah what do you got
cool dot dot I just want some decimal
places now here's the thing
just like in Pythagoras right is that
the answer do i yes no yes
now just like in Pythagoras this is not
like the beside this is the length of
the side squared so I don't want that
you yeah you're thinking what my sense
check is already tingly okay this is not
the length of a side it's been squared
so what do i do my calculator take the
square root
don't approximate yet you should always
approximate last give me three decimal
places for this three okay that's fine
yeah are they always it they're not all
zeros on it
so eventually is a four okay fine so
there it is to some number of decimal
places what does the question require
two so a is 8.30 to two decimal places
is that okay done skis write the cosine
rule is lovely it works quite nicely
okay now on your textbook flip forward a
few pages I don't know how many actually
two pages two pages
okay now we're gonna need to a again but
in the next exercise okay so here it is
right here let's see if we can flex our
you know our trigonometric muscles and
do this again without a diagram what are
you being asked to find have a look
you're asked to find alpha which is an
angle so therefore you can see I've
robbed off the other one cuz I needed
space I'm going to use this form of the
cosine rule same rule just geared
towards a different idea so I'm gonna
say cos of alpha that's the angle I want
it equals to alright let's have a look a
B and C correspond to the three sides
here remember I said one is special
which one is different to the others the
opposite one which in this case is 10 so
therefore this is the C this is the
opposite side so I'll make these a and B
is that okay so on the numerator what
will I write five squared plus 7 squared
takeaway 10 squared you okay with that
so look okay what do I divide by 2 a B
which in this case is 2 times 5 times 7
okay this just like it was before is
calculator work so you're going to get a
number out of here what number do you
get can I get three decimal places from
you
anyone getting it negative negative 0.5
yes no 3/7 not on top I'm getting him
I'm hearing a few different answers just
be careful with your calculator yeah
that looks good now this is clearly not
the angle right it's negative for
starters so the reason why is because
this is not alpha it's cos alpha so what
do I do cos inverse give me some decimal
places okay this is my uh approximated
answer so then I look at the question to
work out how I should approximate what
is it one nearest degree that's really
nice I don't even need to hit my degrees
me the second button whoops I can
clearly see that's going to be 112 now
this is a great example because I want
you to pause for a moment and just look
at the answer firstly sense check it
look good it does look good yeah even
approximately but I want you to notice
something really cool about the cosine
rule it's actually the reason why the
cosine rule is better than the sine rule
remember the sine will had a problem
remember you'd find an angle like this
but then it's like hey sometimes you
didn't find the angle you've found the
base angle right the sine rule doesn't
find a cute sorry
the sine law doesn't find obtuse angles
but the cosine rule does okay now again
what why is that well the question
you're asking is this question and I can
happily answer it for you if you like
but for now I just want you to remember
that the cosine rule is superior to the
side rule if you can choose because
sometimes you can choose now this is the
one you should use okay